-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, yeah. No, well, that's -
that's not great.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I --
I hope -- I hope it doesn'
happen again, either.
Alright.
Let's get to the news.
[ Laughter ]
Yesterday was Father's Day
and, if you forgot to call him
that's actually what he wanted
During a conservative conference
in Florida last week,
former Vice President Mike Pence
was booed
and called a "traitor."
And it takes an awful lot
to make me feel bad
for Mike Pence,
because that didn't.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Mike Pence
was booed at a conservativ
conference in Florida.
Of course, a few months ago,
they were trying to kill him
Getting booed is
the Mike Pence equivalent
of a standing ovation.
According to a new book,
former President Trump suggested
that Americans who were abroad
and infected with coronaviru
should be sent
to Guantánamo Bay,
so the number of cases
would not increase.
This brings us
to our new segment,
"Seth Discovers He Can Still
Experience Shock."
♪♪♪♪
Huh!
Even after everything.
I mean, wow.
Okay.
-This has been...
[ Laughter ]
-Republicans --
Well, no one's going
to be able to hear it.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, the words are on the screen.
Republican --
Republican Senator
Lindsey Graham said,
in an interview yesterday,
that if President Biden want
"an infrastructure deal
of $1 trillion,
it's there for the taking.
Added Graham, "Go on.
It's right over there,
under that crate,
propped up with a stick.
A New York City Council
candidate
is receiving attention onlin
after a video of him
visiting a dominatrix
was posted to Twitter.
The whole incident was
so humiliating,
he gave the dominatrix
an extra $1,000.
[ Laughter ]
Track legend Usain Bolt
and his wife yesterday
announced the birth
of their twins,
Saint and Thunder Bolt.
And you just have to feel
for whichever of them
came out second.
[ Laughter ]
The New York Times yesterday
published a report
detailing a lab analysis
of Subway's tuna sandwich.
They had a feeling
something fishy
wasn't going on.
[ Laughter ]
Nice one from Karen.
Really edging
into Goldich territory.
[ Laughter ]
Carnival Cruise Line
told customers last week
that a data breach
may have exposed
the personal information
of employees and customers, so
if you've been
on a Carnival cruise recently,
now, you have a second problem
[ Laughter ]
Lawmakers in Connecticut
passed a bill last week
to legalize the use
of recreational marijuana,
and just look how many nec
sweaters are already untied.
And, finally,
according to a recent study,
scientists believe
a species of fish
can have pregnancies that last
up to five years
or, more likely,
she's playing you, bro.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
you guys.